build it draw it plan
Vsauce this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is bdp Walden Tom Cuthbert and
Daniel Valdez built an animatronic
Admiral Ackbar costume the eye movement
of the mass is hooked up to Daniels
glasses he plans on using more motors
for mouth movement in the future and
here he is at DragonCon with the full
costume dr. a is an English artist who
creates incredible steampunk style toys
the prolific artist has a ton of
original sculptures and toys on his
website spooky pop and he uses a variety
of materials including brass vinyl
rubber and steel as well as found
objects to bring his wild imagination to
life find the link below for more Jon
English is a toy builder that creates
his own masters of the universe action
figures his deviantART page is filled
with custom interpretations of the
original toys as well as some entirely
new characters of his own including war
wolf swamp chomp and sim tour this
Batcave was built out of 20,000 Lego
bricks Carlisle Livingston at Wayne Hugh
seat but more than 800 hours into this
piece and it weighs over a hundred
pounds and also features LED Christmas
and flash lights draw maniac pumpkin
carvers is a work of Mark Evan and Chris
Soria both artists do illustration and
visual design on their own but they
combine their talents to carve some of
the coolest pop-culture inspired
pumpkins that are available for online
ordering at maniac pumpkin carvers calm
Dita Von Teese creates finger portraits
of famous figures the Italian artist has
dubbed the project did ology and it
features manipulated finger photos
depicting everyone from Spock and mr. t
to Mickey Mouse and Mozart and now for
the comic book artistry of Australia's
Tristen Jones
happy little trees is a tribute to PBS
painting legend bob ross going on at the
screaming sky gallery find the link
below to check out more of the awesomely
afro e prince playing the Bubble organ
was built by Aaron Wendel and directs
airflow to harness the sound of bubbles
musician and comedian Matt Griffo just
released this music video for his song
ghosts ghouls goblins and some guy named
Gary Greg school is some dining Gary
Greg and will torture you until you die
of fright or torture the ghosts who look
behind you and then take you by surprise
while the gunda speaker's has the blood
the Goblin whispers a new year I'll kill
you two and then Gary gravel pointing
laugh at you he's just some dude
good avy bite is a YouTube channel with
a bunch of pop-culture musical parodies
this one is the walking dead musical
wife is hard for the walking dead when
stop run they make space my head
finally an animated crocheted octopus is
the star of Wax Taylor's new video for
the song time to go
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo
click here listen to the tenth
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi - an entire video dedicated
to your creations and as always thanks
for watching